a recent surge in migrants crossing into
the u.s. from Mexico caused agitation at
the White House this week in a tweet
Thursday President Trump threatened to
call up the military and close the
southern border the issue reportedly led
to a heated shouting match between two
of the presidents top advisors arrests
of migrant families have been surging
since the end of the family separation
policy there were nearly 17,000 in
September the Department of Homeland
Security says that's the most on record
for any month and an 80 percent increase
from July
Mireya Villarreal is near the border in
Arizona the recent surge is overwhelming
government facilities and forcing ice to
quickly release migrants just hours
after they're arrested family
apprehensions by the Border Patrol in
Arizona increased by a hundred and
twenty one percent this year as compared
to last in an interview with 60 minutes
lesley stahl president Trump was
reluctant to say whether he'd reinstate
the policy when you allow the parents to
stay together okay when you allow that
then what happens is people are going to
pour into our country you're gonna go
back to that well we're looking at a lot
of things really what we want to do is
change the immigration laws parents we
spoke to say the administration's
decision to pause the practice of
separating families is one of the
reasons they decided to cross the border
now the guy told you that you weren't
going to be separated from your child
mm-hmm that's the reason this is the
border fence that separates Nogales
Arizona from Mexico once these groups
cross into the US illegally they are
actively searching for agents so they
can turn themselves in Border Patrol
says smugglers are taking advantage of
the uncertainty they think they're gonna
get a free ticket into the u.s. well
that's the that's the perceived notion
and that's
what the smugglers were telling them and
what they're selling that journey has
the United Church of Christ is one of
seven Tucson churches that have become
temporary homes for migrant families
just released by ice the gates just
opened very suddenly I think we got 800
people the fight for asylum now moves to
close courts in the meantime these
church doors will remain open for CBS
this morning Saturday v-day of Yale
Tucson Arizona